just don't bunch and outturn all the
world models for more than a decade she
spent more than half her life at the
height of the fashion world the 36
year-old mother of two and wife of NFL
quarterback Tom Brady recently retired
from the runway she is now pursuing her
long-held passion of advocating for the
environment and her business career she
has teamed up with author Paul Hawken
his new book is drawdown it explores
solutions to climate change we talk both
of them when interview will see only on
CBS this morning I believe we are
spiritual beings having a human
experience and I believe that planet
Earth is like you know is a spaceship
let's put it that way
she's been hailed as one of the great
beauties of the world in this spaceship
life is very fragile in a way but
retired supermodel Gisele Bundchen is
now hoping to turn the world's gaze from
the dazzle of the catwalk to the
condition of the planet this planet I
mean look at it fruits growing trees you
know the earth provide us food rivers
all the animals all the species I mean
we are blessed we are living in heaven
here I mean come on having stepped off
the runway last year bündchen uses her
global platform to advocate for the
environment the whole thing that we're
seeing right now it is not yet exploring
deforestation in the Amazon it's so
inspiring working as a UN goodwill
ambassadors and now addressing climate
change with environmentalist Paul Hawken
helping promote his latest book drawdown
what is drawdown drawdown is the first
time in greenhouse gases peak and go
down on a year-to-year basis none of
that happens too well we don't know but
the point we try to make a network is
that nobody's aiming for Hawkins book
list 100 solutions to reverse global
warming all based on existing science
and right by cost and carbon impact so
this book inspired you to have goals and
for everybody else to have a goal I saw
oh my god someone is actually addressing
solution someone is focusing on the
solutions here instead of focusing on
the problems like how can I help how do
I sign up to help and that's how I I
that's why how I'm here I've been trying
to tell the story
and I feel as if I failed it's been 10
years I think since An Inconvenient
Truth
yes the Al Gore film and book yeah why
haven't we done more the science is
impeccable however the communication of
the science has been miserable because
it is focused on threat I'm gloom and
the idea somehow that will get people to
act if we scare the pee out of them
actually hasn't worked at all I hear you
talking about the fact that you got to
have a plan you got to be optimistic you
got to understand of what you can do but
at the same time I know a lots of people
who are saying that unless we do
something immediately it's going to be
catastrophic
and I agree and then what I'm saying is
we're acting this is in place it is
scaling and if we continue to scale in a
rigorous but reasonable way over 30
years we can reverse global why we will
put our miners back to work for now the
two claim to be unfazed by the Trump
administration's efforts to revive the
coal industry and roll back
environmental rules you have to be
concerned about national policy you have
to be concerned about what the EPA is
doing or not doing right yes I I mean I
feel that you know I just like to I'm an
optimist
so I believe that what all of this noise
is doing I feel is bringing more
awareness and I think now people are
just more kind of feeling like you know
I have to take the matters to my own
hands like I have to get educated I have
to learn I have to kind of figure out
how we're going to do this I have to do
something here but don't you think we
should be a catalyst to try if you
disagree with government policy try to
change it yeah yes but I think the way
you do that is by bringing for the
information because I think we are all
learning right and leave that what we
believe right if our Commission is like
you know in my situation like we have a
plant-based diet and we've been having
it for 10 years and why is that because
a because we feel better it is better
for our health and everything we put
into our body has an effect on us has an
effect on our energy and how we feel and
and your husband says Tom Brady says
unless I had this plant-based diet he
would not be the player I am yes
I wouldn't have the career at 39 yeah
that I do
he's almost 40 right ah tell him that I
was like don't say that no but he did
thing is he said he's been feeling so
much better I have to say it's amazing
you know the way he feels he doesn't
feel achy he just feels so much more
energy and you're very just an
initiative by you did you influence how
you're a house and your husband and your
children feel about plant-based diet and
other things is that come from gizelle
yes what day long I don't you want to
say no it does it has it has come free
because you know I have um so he has his
creator thing you know he has to thank
his commitment in his education to it
because he still has to want to do it
right Yuki in the beginning he was like
it was a little you know different for
him but now he loves it and he wouldn't
have it any other way because he feels
better your husband said the other day
that you wanted him to retire he said
that not me you know this thing is and
that he was gonna play as long as he
felt as good as he does now yeah are you
trying to get him to retire you know I
just have to say as a wife I'm a little
bit you know it's as you know it's not
the most like um let's say an aggressive
sport right football like he had a
concussion last year I mean he has
concussions pretty much it I mean we
don't talk about but he does have
concussions and he's I don't really
think it's a healthy thing for your body
to go to like a you know to that kind of
aggression like all the time that could
not be healthy for you right and I'm
planning on having him be healthy and do
a lot of fun things when we're like 100
I hope where would you put the Super
Bowl victory in the great things that
happened to your family it was a
wonderful um and uh you know very
emotional you know I saw that victory as
something much bigger than just a
victory of like a team playing another
team I thought there was an amazing
message there I was like you know what
for all the people who feel like you
know when they're losing like they give
up or they never give up like if you're
here if you're standing if you're
breathing there is a way you know and as
long as we have focus and dedication and
clarity of purpose
you're going to make it happen Wow just
heard is the reason she's so very
successful and also the reason Tom Brady
is so very successful yeah but there is
a good message there that when it seems
like it can't be done just don't give up
I love her enthusiasm though didn't you
I love that she's remember how
passionate yeah really great interview
yeah well I've been a bit her husband
too so then this is uh you understand
them yeah you get them as a couple very
nice you can hear more of our interview
with Giselle and Paul Hawken on the CBS
this morning podcast she shapes how she
shares how she shaped the world